le haschisch
j'aime vachement de toute façon au
tennis on ne fait jamais de contrôler
les meilleurs comme pesci et borg se
drogue avant les matchs sur conseils de
leur médecin
ces déclarations sans détour c'est le
français yannick noah qui les a faites
dans le mensuel de jeunes rock and folk
vous imaginez facilement qu'elles ont eu
l'effet d'une bombe dans le monde
sportif
alors avec nous sur ce plateau celui qui
a recueilli ses déclarations de yannick
noah thierry ardisson thierry ardisson
vous savez que cette interview est déjà
contestée alors dans quelles conditions
et comment c'était le fait elle s'est
fait chez nos à un après midi entre 5
heures et 7 heures et demie à paris à
paris oui la vente donc ils partent à
flushing meadow avant qu'il parte à
vichy pour s'entraîner tiens tu aurais
mais noah et et il avertit du caractère
un peu sensationnaliste de cet article
de cette ethnie il avait lu les quatre
autres interviews qu'on avait fait ce
dans la même série dont il connaissait
le style est il de descente de police
vous est il parut conscient de la portée
des réponses qu'il a apportées à vos
questions et des vagues trop grave vous
savez que nous a déclaré dans l'équipe
ce matin mes propos ont été déformés
je sais que c'est grave mais ce que l'on
me rapporte n'est pas conforme à ce que
j'ai déclaré les propos n'ont pas été
déformé ce qui est des formes et c'est
ce que vous avez annoncé tout à l'heure
il a jamais dit que box drogué il a dit
que c'était possible
c'était possible sésame il a dit qu'il
était à peu près sûr que pesci étaient
drogués à l'époque de de roland garros
l'année dernière
est ce que vous avez fait lire où vous
avez lu à yannick noah avant de publier
si je n'interviens jamais nous l'a pas
demandé en répondant à vos questions
noah pouvait envisager le problème sous
deux angles celui du doping devient
malheureusement chose courante en sport
je vais aussi celui de l'usagé la drogue
qui tenta de venir dans certains milieux
sportifs il ya là une nuance qui peut
être a échappé à noah aussi non mais je
crois que tout le monde sait que les que
les tennismen prennent par exemple des
amphétamines avant les matches
simplement personne ne le dit et non à
l'a dit et je crois que pour ça il faut
quand même lui reconnaître moi le
courage de l'avoir dit justement c'est
une des questions que l'on peut se poser
at il témoigné de courage d'inconscience
ou de 3,6
je crois que sont le ton était tout à
fait tout à fait clair il a dit il faut
qu'il le dit dans l'article il faut le
dire avant qu'il y ait des morts comme
au cyclisme et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de in a l'habitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus